A CRUISE SHIP HAS RESCUED SEEM
HUMAN MIGRANT STRANDED ON CNN
MAKESHIFT ROCK.
THIS VIDEO WILL SHOW THEM USING
--
PADDLE TOWARDS THE SHIP WHICH
WAS BOUND FROM MEXICO.
AN EYEWITNESS SAYS THAT IT
LOOKS LIKE A PIECE OF FURNITURE
POSSIBLY A CABINET.
JOINING ME NOW CNN'S PATRICK
OLBERMANN, PATRICK, WHAT DO WE
KNOW MORE ABOUT --
AND THEIR WELFARE?
>> ACCORDING TO THE CAPTAIN
AFTER THE SIX MIGRANTS WERE
RESCUED TO THE PASSENGERS THAT
THEY WERE DEHYDRATED, BUT
OTHERWISE --
WE KNOW FROM REPRESENTATIVES
AND CRUISE LINE THAT THEY WERE
GIVING FOOD, WATER AND CLOTHING
AND THAT --
TWO MEXICAN WHEN THE SHIP
ARRIVED IN MEXICO IT REMAINS TO
BE SEEN WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ASKED FOR ASYLUM OR WILL BE
OVERTURNED BACK TO CUBA SO
OFTEN HAPPENS WHEN MIGRANTS
COME FROM CUBA ARRIVE IN
MEXICO.
BUT IT REALLY IS, AN INCREDIBLE
VIDEO BUT ALSO SHOWS THE
DESPERATION THAT MANY HERE ARE
FEELING, BECAUSE THESE ARE BOTH
WE SEE EVERY DAY, PEOPLE ARE
JUST OFF THE COAST THEY ARE NOT
MEANT FOR CROSSING THE 90 MILES
TO THE UNITED STATES.
AND CERTAINLY, THIS GROUP OF
MIGRANTS WAS SO LUCKY BECAUSE
THEIR WAY, WAY OFF COURSE.
REALLY, INCREDIBLY LUCKY THAT
THEY WERE FOUND BY THE SHIP
ESPECIALLY AS ONE OF THE
PASSENGERS TOLD US THERE WAS A
STORM HOURS AFTER THEY WERE
PICKED UP.
THEY WERE SEEING A SURGE IN
CUBANS LEAVING THIS ISLAND,
MOST --
AND THEN TRY TO CROSS THE
BORDER IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE HUNDRED 75,000 SO FAR THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
IT'S ABOUT 1% OF THE POPULATION
OF CUBA REALLY AN INCREDIBLE
NUMBER WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
AND THE COAST GUARD HAS BEEN
REPORTED AN UPTICK IN PEOPLE
TAKING SMALL RAFTS, BOATS JUST
LIKE THIS ONE AND WE SEE IN THE
VIDEO TO TRY TO GET TO T